una posible nueva herramienta en la
lucha contra el hobbit 19 se llama mon
lupera beer y es el antiviral
experimental de la farmacéutica merck
cuyos resultados sorprenden a la
comunidad médica la pastilla promete la
reducción de las posibilidades de
hospitalización o muerte en un 50% tras
contraer el virus y
disponer de una pastilla para prevenir
la evolución a una enfermedad grave
cambiaría la forma de tratarla
las personas podrían ir a su farmacia y
tomar su medicación de la misma manera
que lo hacen con otros medicamentos esto
nos permitiría tratar a muchas más
personas con mayor rapidez y menos
gastos extensos está se administra a los
pacientes que han contraído el cubit 19
recientemente y se toman dos dosis
diarias durante cinco días entre las 775
personas que se sometieron a la fase 3
del estudio no hubo muertes entre los
pacientes que tomaron el mono pira beer
y sólo ocho personas del grupo que tomó
el placebo murieron tras el experimento
la noticia tuvo sus impactos en el
mercado mientras que las acciones de
merck subieron un 12% de los fabricantes
de vacunas como facer o modernas cayeron
a pesar de que las autoridades
sanitarias consideran que los resultados
son impresionantes defienden la
vacunación como primera opción
si se aprueba creo que la forma correcta
de pensar en esto es que se trata de una
herramienta adicional para proteger a
las personas de los peores resultados
del cobi 19 creo que es realmente
importante recordar que la vacunación
sigue siendo de lejos la mejor de
nuestras armas
beijing no obstante el gobierno ya ha
cerrado un contrato de 17 millones de
dosis con merck que se materializará
siempre y cuando las autoridades
sanitarias aprueben su uso de emergencia
el próximo objetivo del laboratorio es
desarrollar las pastillas para que se
puedan usar también para prevenir el cob
y 19